[Music]
catherine is in uh springfield missouri
hi catherine welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
awesome and also i just want to thank
you for your show because i find it very
encouraging
i'm not one of the smart people or the
big money earners
but i am
single
and
dependent only on myself and it's just
been very encouraging to me to to hear
your show and
just keep plugging along well we are
honored to have you and you're among
friends because ken and i are not one of
the smart people either
especially me emphasis on ken
[Laughter]
hey we you know hey i love uh slightly
above average students who go out and
become successful and that's me and you
that's the three of us how can we help
today
well i have gotten two credit card
companies that have sent me
new cards they're identical to the old
card only they include the tap to pay
and i'm tempted to
destroy the new ones since they're
identical
but i'm just wondering is
is there a reason i should keep the tap
to pay
well tap to pay in and of itself is not
bad of course we teach people to only
use debit cards
i don't have i don't have any credit
cards i have debit cards and debit cards
today um almost all of them have a chip
in them
and that's that's all come about in
really the last four years or so in the
u.s it was widespread in europe before
it was here but most of our debit and
credit cards now have a chip
and so when you uh for instance i'm
buying gas this morning and i put it
into the uh the gas pump it it
identifies with the chip that it is a
debit card it doesn't used to have to
ask me if it was a debit or credit now
it identifies it and tells me to put in
my pin
um and a matter of fact a lot of the
credit cards now have you put in a pin
as well on a pay on a point of sale
transfer because they're trying to do
that to avoid uh fraud and so forth but
uh the biggest thing you want to
remember with all these products is just
the easier they make the transaction to
occur the more you buy
right
and that's the only thing as long as you
know that as long as you know that in
your guard against it you know it's like
amazon prime it's a very easy
transaction you can just sit there and
push that little button all day and crap
will show up on your front porch you
know it's just it's just really really
easy and you tend to spend more the
easier it is to do the transaction the
harder more cumbersome the transaction
marketers call that friction
uh then the more it slows you down and
makes you realize you're actually doing
a transaction you're actually giving
someone money so as long as you're aware
of that i don't care if you use apple
pay i don't care if you wave a wand and
do a dance
i uh p i mean there's all kinds of
different ways to pay for things these
days but all of them just about are
trying to make it easier and easier and
easier to do the transaction because all
the merchants know
that consumers spend more that way
yeah
yeah well mine usually stay in the
drawer
but i have my house on the market right
now
so my realtor said don't leave things in
the drawer so i have to keep them in my
purse and i'm wondering is it safe to
keep these in my purse yeah yeah i mean
you're fine because it's got fraud
protection on it if they got stolen you
just turn it in for fraud you're not
you're not responsible for transactions
on a thefted credit card
now if somebody took it out and used it
and put it back it might be a little
while before you realized it when you
got the statement or something but um
but that would be true of a debit card
or anything else and again
we tell you to not use credit cards at
all
uh a debit card will do everything a
credit card will do except put you into
debt it has the exact same protections
for fraud the exact it's just as safe i
still see stupid people on the internet
say oh i got i don't carry a debit card
it's not safe it's just exactly as safe
as your credit card if if you misuse
your credit card you get to pay for it
if someone misuses your credit card for
you call fraud or theft you don't have
to pay for it same is true with a debit
card it's all exactly the same ken yeah
it is and there's just this myth out
there and i think that's do you think
the credit card companies are behind all
that dave i suspect maybe they are
well urban legends out there sure they
don't you know of course if you go to
wheat if you go to visa or mastercard's
website you'll see it it's a zero
liability policy on both their sites
for both products debit or credit either
one and our bank protects us they vife
go to a other city in the country and i
i finally tell them ahead of time
they'll stop purchases as a protection
that's why they'll do that on credit or
debt yes they will because they are
liable for the
fraudulent transactions